everyone that I know is in a pivotal
moment of transformation it doesn't
matter what stage of life you're in but
I think giving ourselves the permission
to recommit and like redefine what is
the relationship is great Freedom it's
not necessarily comfortable or easy but
isn't that in fact our mission to know
each other why else are we together it
has been profound what we have
experienced as a couple in honoring that
our relationship deserves our presence
and to see what is waiting for us to
ReDiscover and uncover it's a whole new
slate it's a whole new canvas I think
the possibilities are
endless today is all about intimacy
we're going to talk about Intimacy in
relationships how to evolve a long-term
relationship Beyond calcified habits and
routines expectations and projections
and instead summon the courage to truly
see your partner and allow yourself to
be seen by your partner plus we're going
to talk about Lessons Learned From the
front lines of startup entrepreneurship
and we're going to do this through the
lens and through the experience of my
wife and our 23 years together the most
recurring guest in the history of this
podcast Julie Patt longtime listeners
are well acquainted with Julie's
mystical way days with wisdom but if
this happens to be your first
introduction to the one who goes by
shrimati uh what you need to know is
that she is a truly multi-talented and
multi-dimensional being she's a yogi
musician Chef designer author Mama of
four and the founder and CEO of Shu the
best and only plant-based cheese you
need concern yourselves with Julie is
graciously gifting all of you guys with
a a special deal on Shu when you sign up
for an annual subscription to any of
shu's ebox offerings at sho.com she's
kindly rewarding you with the 13th box
free when you use the code RRP fam 13 at
checkout as well as 22% off the brand
new ceremony box which includes 2 8 oz
mlay chocolate mousse cakes shu's newest
and first dessert offering when you use
the code
ml22 ma L A y22 at checkout sho.com all
right let's get into
it hi Julie pie first of all rich can I
just hold your hand across this
table yeah I mean it's I'm a little
close on the mic though there
yeah no it's been a long time that we've
been 12T away is this it Universe no I
mean the the RP table oh yes yeah
exactly the last time you were here the
table was still long right yeah this is
the first time okay I'm feeling you're
happy very uh intimate well I always
enjoy uh having you on the most frequent
guest in the history of the podcast and
while I was in um Atlanta at this
running man event which I'll share about
in a minute um lots of people coming up
to say that their favorite episode
episodes are the ones with you same in
Memphis a that's sweet I appreciate that
and typically We Begin these
conversations with a bunch of hand
ringing around uh the leadup to the
conversation and me pestering you about
finding time to sit down so we can hash
out what we're going to talk about uh
but I didn't do that this time so you
should be proud of me I TR this is trust
this is intimacy Julie yeah you didn't
do it last time but you really didn't do
it this time time yeah really you really
didn't I I very intentionally you didn't
even give me a look it wasn't even like
a look like have you thought about what
you're going to talk about on my
show right now I'm tempted to say have
you but I didn't I'm not saying that
even though I kind of just did yeah
definitely now I have but I'm just open
to what the moment will present so how
are we doing I think we're doing pretty
well don't you I think so we're in we're
at an interesting moment in our in our
marriage in our relationship this moment
I think it's a uh a transitionary phase
we're in a semi
um uh new space with uh two of our young
our two youngest out of the house the
boys still live with us but they're like
roommates because they're older um and
so now we're liberated from having to
pick people up wherever or you know cook
lots of food for lots of different
people it's quieter at the house um but
sudden L it's like oh hey who are you
you know we don't have to be the
transportation department anymore
exactly um and so I think there's a um a
process of trying to get to know each
other in a new and different way that
has presented itself which is an
opportunity but also you know a little
scary we've been together for 23 years
is that the number yeah I mean we
started dating in '99 yeah yeah that's
true 23 years so pretty amazing how are
you feeling about everything I'm feeling
great actually about it I think it's a I
think it's a moment of and you know
listen every parent every couple that
has kids that are listening to this you
know you guys are all know the drill
yeah the empty well what it's like when
you have the kids and your relationship
sort of becomes about you know the MTA
like who's picking up who and who's
getting what and it becomes very not
necessarily transaction but logistical
in nature yeah definitely I mean Can Can
it can it can but I think apart from
that I mean apart from that because that
does not define our entire relationship
I mean we're not really a couple that's
been mired in who's picking who up so
much no but you know it's it is a you
know complicated decision Tree on days
about like who's going where when and
how they going to get there and all that
kind of stuff like that does that can
predominate at times and it has
throughout you
we've done
good that our relationship isn't all
about that but obviously we're both
sympathetic to what that's like for
parents who are raising kids and you
know they have needs and places they
need to go and all that kind of stuff
and so your relationship can
become um out of balance and overly kind
of um capitalized by those types of
conversations at the cost of what
brought you together in the first place
yeah definitely I do I feel like what
we're experiencing is something much
deeper than that it's more uh an
opportunity of recommitting in a new way
and of understanding that we've
experienced many many things in 23 years
that include uh children and creative
projects and um experiences of life and
um loss of life and you know all the
things that are in a lifetime of 23
years and I think that we are for many
different reasons in a place of
redefining what that commitment is and I
think that one of the exciting things is
that we have come to a point of
understanding that in order to move
through so that there is no way out
there is only through and in order to
move through we have to be willing to uh
basically uh burn or uh transmute that
entire
relationship of those unspoken
agreements or expectations or
projections of what each other have been
of of what we've been to each other in
order to make room for something new and
so you know the Julian Rich that you
know has been chronicled on this podcast
for all the years of the podcast for 10
plus years um that relationship is is
complete it's it's it's been fulfilled
in in that form and so one of the great
things that I think that is really
exciting is that uh we are going into
deeper layers of our relationship and
where we might transcend evolve and
become from this point forwards mhm and
for me that's not oh the the kids have
been in and we've been taking them
places that's yeah I understand very but
but that is kind of like a benchmark
where you can plant a flag and and and
easily see a demarcation line between
what was before and what what is to come
definitely um and it's a it's a it's a
dynamic that is equal parts exciting but
also
terrifying
um
because it is forcing me to get out of
my comfort zone and the comfortable kind
of ruts and routines that just make life
go easy and to uh you know offer up like
a deeper level of honesty and sharing
with you um which is scary because you
know I kind of like things the way they
are and it's easy and you know it's it's
fine um and you're
like I want to know all of you and I was
like do you really I don't know if you
really do I don't know if I want to
share you know like what does that mean
um so there is a you know I I have a um
built-in you know default setting that
that that makes me recoil when you
present me with that yes um but I also
recognize the opportunity and I don't
want to and I'm and I'm very aware that
you know a relationship is never static
just like anything like you're either
moving towards each other or away from
each other and we're faced with a choice
right now because we can't to stay the
way that we've always been if we do that
it is a it you know it is a a vote for
Decay and I don't want to Decay and I
don't want to be divorced from you or
separated from you I do want to move
toward you um but just not that deeply
yeah like maybe a little bit we'll see
you know we'll see how that goes I'll
dip my toe in that um yeah we laugh but
it is true it's a little scary for me
and you're so good about
creating
um ritual and you know kind of symbolism
around that to really uh Infuse that
decision or this conversation with a
deeper level of intentionality that
makes it more three-dimensional than
just like well we talked about that and
we'll see how it goes right like we did
a fire ceremony so maybe you can walk
through that I mean the importance of
ritual and what ritual means to you is
something we've talked about in the past
on the podcast so I don't want to
necessarily retread that but I think
there is something to be said for
investing in the Paw
necessary so that a
decision and a new way forward can plant
its roots so that it becomes um more
capable of of of fruiting I guess of
fruiting yeah that's the first time I've
heard that word in a very long time well
if you're going to if you want fruit you
need Roots right fr people yeah if your
roots aren't good the fruit is not going
to so is not going to but I mean where
this came from is you know first of all
you know a point in evolution um but I
was telling you that one of the most
beautiful moments that I ever gazed upon
you was after go on what is it do you
have like a more do you have more a more
intellectual word for gazed upon you you
want no I'm saying like this is my ego
like this so please continue okay was
when uh after you had finished Ultram
man that famous race where I was your
crew Captain um you were just stripped
bare of everything that burdens you that
chase you chases you that haunts you
that makes you run away from me that
makes you run away from life or people
and you were just raw and in that state
you were just a sight of such beauty and
what I shared with you recently was that
I want to know you at that level and I
want to be known at that level and I
told you I'm coming for you so it's not
like um you know it's not like you know
you can just run away and hide because
I'm I'm asking for presence is what I'm
asking I'm asking to be courageous
enough to sit with me and see me in my
presence even though it scares you even
though we may discover something that we
don't know about each other that we
haven't shared yet and it's hard to
imagine that we we could be together 23
years and there could still be aspects
of our s that we don't that we haven't
shared but I think that that's true I
think that we all are hiding something
or never felt comfortable revealing
something and it it's really a focus
because what you were really speaking to
when you were talking about picking up
and is it's losing the presence of your
relationship to a
routine and it's easy to it's easier to
not be present right it can sometimes be
a lot easier to distract yourself and
you know it's I'm busy it's work or
there's Netflix or there's training or
there's you know and it's not just you
it's just whatever it is in life and and
for me it's like you know if you think
that we may be alive 20 more years
neither one of us uh took vows or got
into this relationship so that we could
sit on the couch and say we've arrived
like that hasn't been the theme of our
relationship and even in the way that we
come to this table in Stripes you know
it's demonstrated in the jacket that you
have on and the stripes that I have on
we're very different beings we're from
very very different perspectives and the
beauty of that is when we can come
together and that friction creates the
Alchemy that's the beauty of this
relationship and so really the question
is is what else is there for us to
discover and do we have the courage to
go there even though it may reveal
something new you know something
different and I feel like a lot of
people right now uh in relationships are
going through this very process so I
think it's very exciting I mean we
definitely have been a lot more intimate
and connected than we've been in years
and you know it's sort of like a whole
new frontier it's a whole new slate it's
a whole new canvas and so um I think the
possibilities are endless
and I'm coming for you yeah I know see
it's terrifying what am I supposed to do
with that you're coming for me no I
don't mean that like it's like a threat
no you know I'm coming for you and I'm
going to know you and you're going to
know me and I'm
like okay what about that scares you uh
I don't know I just I think you know I
am you like to be
unknown it's not that I like to be
unknown there is a resistance to or or
just like sort of a a a zone of privacy
that you know feels like like a comfort
zone that um I'm reluctant to to you
know forsake well you'll still have
privacy but you know it doesn't have to
be like I'm coming for you like you're
like I'm gunning for you well no I mean
the thing I mean that can be a beautiful
thing it can be a romantic thing it's
not like a an Annihilation thing right
yeah so I mean from your side what is it
that you want to know about me or what
what is it like or do you do you do you
have the same uh uh now I'm really on
the spot desire no here's the thing hold
on excuse me um of course like I do
think that we have been in you know kind
of an extended period of habituation to
a norm and our relationship no
relationship can survive that right like
if you don't change then you will be
changed and that you know a relationship
is not immune from that so uh
I'm very cognizant of the need to
elevate you know the way that we
interact with each other um and I'm
deeply aware that I want to be with you
I don't want to be without you I don't
want to be away from you I want to be
with you would you even say you want to
be close to
me would you would you say that you want
to know me at the de aspect of me as
long as I get to Retreat to my corner
occasionally and like you know charge my
battery up dude you sleep in a tent I
have my own private
quarters you know psychologist wet dream
to try to figure out that whole thing
right so we'll see how it goes I'm game
for it you know I'm looking forward to
it it's already it's already paid
dividends in terms of our connection I
think we have a long I feel good I feel
I feel much closer to you I feel aligned
with you I feel um I mean it feels
really good to just celebrate you like
to just go to Memphis and it's about you
and Shu and that's the only reason that
I'm there and I'm not trying to like
sneak off and check my phone or make it
about me or any of the you know kind of
Character defects that typically Croc up
crop up um that involve my ego and
insecurities um and it was beautiful to
just be in reverence of of you and and
in celebration of what you achieved in
this Vision that you have um and I think
uh you know I I definitely want more of
that and I know that um you are like in
terms of like what are our needs and are
our needs being met right and what are
the wounds that we both bring into this
equation that flare up when those needs
aren't getting met um and understanding
those and anticipating how to make sure
that each other's needs are getting met
so that we can um relax into each other
and that intimacy becomes a comfortable
place as opposed to a scary place that I
that that that I find myself throwing
walls up against MH the so the intimacy
is what's scary and that's where the
treasure is that's where the treasure
lies uhhuh so until you until you until
what do you think happens in there like
what do you think Happ that's that's the
fear the fear is if you really know me
you will run in the other direction
because I am fundamentally broken and
unlovable and so I front a certain way
to be a certain person who can uh create
the appearance of
lovability and to some level uh you know
I can sustain that but I have to retreat
into my corner to charge the battery
because that requires a lot of En Tak
takes a lot of energy right so when you
drop all of that and you're like well
this is who I am that's terrifying
because you know there is something deep
down that feels like if you really knew
me like you would you would you would
you would find me you know
repulsive but in the knowing you is
where the true intimacy is and without
Shadow so you say no without Shadow
there really isn't there really isn't
any love and I mean I can share this one
I can share this one experience recently
which was quite enlightening for me and
that is that we had a date night we went
to the movies and we went to one of
those places where it's like reclining
and you can order food and the whole
thing and so when we get to our seats I
realize that you have bought two seats
that are not together it's like over
exaggerating happened let me just say
let me just tell he bought two seats you
know how when you go and you in the
theater you have two that are together
it's like there's they're a pair right
but what he did is he bought like the
left side and the right right side of
two pairs and so I'm sitting there and
there's this huge like hard space
between us and I'm like dude like what
why did you buy this seat like like and
you're like no I did this on P purpose
because I need to sit in the middle of
the theater because this is where I want
to I need to sit like ever so slightly
to the left of center M because I have
all right go ahead no so I'm so I after
a minute I take a breath I take a breath
and then I'm think to myself okay wow I
can't believe he did this and then I'm
like so I say honey I'm going to go to
the front and I'm going to see if they
can switch my seat because I want to sit
next to him I don't want to hold hands
with him across a table so I go to the
front and the woman moves the seat and I
come to him and I said she moved us to
the right so you it means he had to move
into the pair to the right and you were
completely annoyed and you're like now
I'm not sitting in the middle and like
this is a problem and when I realized is
that that has something to do with your
lazy eye and your sight and so you you
shared with me in that experience that
the world is skewed for you a little bit
all the time and you have to correct for
it but literally that was the first time
I ever understood that after 23 years of
being with you and what it did was it
made me love you more it made me
understand why you made that decision
and I was like oh my God like he's
compensating for that instead of me
feeling like what is wrong with this
dude like why would he choose that well
there's part of there's there's two
parts to it one is the crazy part which
is like I have this weird OCD thing
about like cemetery and like I want to
be in the center seat and have it like
everything has to be like a Wes Anderson
movie where everything is perfectly
aligned on each side um but because my
left eye is so weak I have to be a
little bit to the left because of the
way my eyes work so even though I'm a
little bit to the left of center I I
perceive it as being in the center and
that's that's the neurological piece
that I had never shared with you but
kind of you know I carry with me you had
never even shared really the part I was
watching so so I was watching the David
Beckham documentary which I know you
watched and it's
fantastic anybody who hasn't seen it on
Netflix it's a it's a beautifully
rendered four-part series um but the
parts particularly like in the later
episodes where he's showing uh he's
showing everybody his wardrobe and how
he like organizes all of his clothes and
all of that and I was like see that guy
that's how I think like that's I would I
do the exact same thing he's sort of
like embarrassed yeah and I I don't like
want to talk about that because it's
there's something wrong with me you know
no it's something amazing I mean so
anyway I mean I think it's I is this
bringing us together do you feel do you
feel absolutely I mean this is this is
the definition of intimacy It's like
because if you're hiding something and
you're not you know I mean it only
brings more intimacy and connection
that's all that's all there is in there
and that's what presence brings so I
really appreciate and I I really like
that you shared that with me and it
doesn't make me think oh he's a you know
he's crazy or well there's there's a lot
more there's a lot more weirdness where
that came from we can go all the way
go down there it might be a huge
relief so uh what would you say or
recommend to you know somebody who's
watching or listening who is finds
himself who is sort of finding them
themselves in a relationship where where
it's it's it's somewhat stagnant and
there is that yearning for a deeper
intimacy like how does one who hasn't
who isn't as practiced in this you know
Embark upon on that or raise it with
their partner well I mean I think it's
is having the desire you know is the
most important thing it's not like I'm
an expert at it I haven't digested it
and been through it I I think when you
agreed with me that you wanted to do
this with me I wrote the outline of a
book and sent it to you like within six
hours yeah there's been a lot of
recommended books and other things that
yeah that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
then um and then also I'm I'm exploring
some SE uality books that I don't I'm
not going to share right now because I
haven't digested them and I'm finding
that they're a little off base but they
have they have some core practices that
I think will be useful so like we're
designing I'm designing a Protocol no uh
I'm designing a protocol for us and
we'll see like how how it how it goes
you know what works for us I mean we're
very very good actually in in a room
together like we don't really need a
facilitator you know we do pretty well
together if we're both willing and if
we're both facilitator like you mean
like a therapist you talking about like
a sex therapist like a somebody standing
there when we're trying to like have no
I don't just anything like I'm trying to
visualize what you mean I just meant
like a therapist like we just you know
we we have really good communication
skills and um we've you know we've done
a pretty good job you know communicating
in our relationship and and I mean the
thing this thing that we went through is
largely um connected to co so it was
also that polarization that we were we
were playing it out in our own marriage
and and luckily we were wise enough and
loving enough that we stayed together
through that because you're a you're a
WID stripe suit guy and I'm a poncho
striped you know tablecloth girl so you
know that was a very that was the
challenge and and I would say more so
than driving kids around I I really
think it was that moment on the planet
where everything was being polarized and
so I just want to recognize us that we
are here and that we um found our way to
stay together so
um uh you know I don't know what I would
say really to all of us cuz you know
everyone that I know is in a pivotal
moment of transformation it doesn't
matter what stage of life you're in but
I think giving ourselves the permission
to recommit to recommit and like
redefine what is the relationship is
great freedom and you know the only
thing to fear is fear itself because
there is no way out there's only through
and you know I love you so deeply and I
know you love me so deeply there's no
other way you know there's there's not
walking away there's no walking away we
have to go deeply into each other and
really see what's there and create
something new that will provide the next
Evolution for let's say the next 23
years and it's not necessarily
comfortable or easy but isn't that in
fact our mission to know each other if
we're going to be in relationship isn't
that in fact the true desire to know you
deeply and to be known deeply I mean why
else are we together out of habit or out
of an agreement or out of some social
construct um I don't think that's why
we're together I don't think it's ever
been why we're together and the proof of
that has been this podcast and you know
what is birthed out of our experience
together I mean I told you during these
discussions of recent you know I will
never do what I did with you with anyone
else and you will never do what you did
with me with anyone else it has been
profound what we have experienced as a
couple and in honoring that uh I think
our relationship deserves our presence
and to see what is next what is waiting
for us to ReDiscover and
uncover yeah that's
beautiful I'm with you for that whole
thing awesome as scary as it may be for
me
but
um I don't want to know what the
alternative to that is a thank you and
also thank you for your presence in that
and thank you for meeting me and saying
yes because there's a lot of men that
wouldn't so thank you for being willing
and and being there for me and being
able to say no I'm here you know I'm
right here it means a
lot all right well what is the moment
presenting for you right now just your
cuteness and you know the wico T-shirt
can we talk about Wilco sure I
mean I just saw we took Trapper to uh
the ace theater to see Wilco for his it
was his 27th
birthday and you are a hardcore Wilco
fan for sure I was familiar with some of
the most popular songs um I have never
been so ambushed by a musical act in my
life uh in the way of the the sort of
unassuming way they slid onto the stage
and they're singing uh you know what I
would say is just a sort of maybe um
calm music I don't know just sort of
very ch
music no no just wait but then they they
ended up taking me on this journey that
literally slayed me creatively like I
have never seen a band play at that
level and I it was just so unassuming it
was you know there wasn't like
explosions not not that not that I like
explosions but it it was very subtle you
know in in the way that it that it came
about and I just became became a
gigantic Wilco fan I was absolutely
slayed better better late than never
yeah better late than ever as I as I
told the boys uh that night um I think
going to see Wilco live uh is one of the
last vestiges of authentic uh Gen X of
an authentic Gen X experience like the
crowd was definitely you know like of
the older ilk lot of silver-haired guys
yeah um and I think Jeff Tweety is is
exactly my age but he's you know listen
uh singer songwriter of a generation
surrounded by some of the most masterful
musicians on the planet who just Crush
you know so yeah it's quite it's quite
the experience I definitely want to get
Jeff Tweety on the podcast he has this
well he has a book about to come out but
I think he passed through LA and I
missed the moment while he was here in
town but there are solutions around that
that we said and actually interesting
enough uh one of my team members June
Kim uh became friendly with the basis
wife and so I've already sent them Shu
so I hope shu is finding them on Wilco
is consuming consuming Shu I hope so I
hope so I mean I'd be honored um it was
just really such a beautiful uh deep um
creative uh
original um everything about them was
just extraordinary so anyway it's it's
heartwarming to hear you say that cuz I
didn't I didn't know I as you said I've
been a fan for a long time but I didn't
know that it would connect with you yeah
it did and then actually when we got to
cross town I found out so I went to
cross town Concourse about 10 days ago
to get my Cafe ready for the grand
opening launch um somebody told me that
Wilco had actually played at the radio
station there so um one of the guitar
players is good friends with the founder
of the radio station in Cross toown
Concourse which is the vertical
community in Memphis Tennessee where uh
Shu has just opened up her first
Flagship wine and cheese Cafe in
addition it's where all my production
exists now so it is our home in Memphis
Tennessee Andross town is a vertical
Community it's 1,500,000 Square fet the
size of the Empire State Building on its
side uh and it is um just at the
Forefront of all things beautiful in
life Artisan residency um music
listening libraries recording studios
performance theater
um a new thought high school health care
for 880,000 people the working
uninsured uh and much much more also
Global Cafe run by Refugee women um and
Shu in my opinion has one of the Premier
spots it was spot 13 and it's just at
the base of this beautiful spiral red
modern staircase uh so when you when you
walk up the staircase you're in a
gorgeous Museum that's like a Moma level
Museum um also leading to the
performance theater and green room and
Art Bar um and then at the base of the
stairs is where shimu wi and cheese Cafe
is now uh open and ready for a new life
yeah congratulations thank you so much
um it was my first visit to Memphis so I
just got back from Memphis and then an
event in Atlanta called Running Man that
I'll that I'll talk about but we were
all in Memphis to celebrate the opening
of your Flagship there and you had told
me like you're not going to understand
cross town Concourse until you visit it
you can look at the photos you can go
online you can understand it but until
you're actually there like the scale of
it um is impossible to translate you
know through the phone or whatever and
that was certainly the case like it is a
magnificent um structure but also I
think what struck me the most was the
people behind the vision
the vision that they held for it and
what they were able to manifest Against
All Odds because typically a structure
like that I mean this building was
originally a Sears and robu distribution
facility seers had multiple of these
across the country something like I
don't know six or 10 of them where they
would ship out all their products across
the United States and in the case of the
facility in Memphis there's a train
track that runs right behind it where
they would load all the stuff onto the
train right out of the back um and this
structure went phow in the wake of Sears
going under in the 90s and was decrepit
and falling down um and was purchased uh
by Staley Kates who we met um for I
don't know what like $2 million
something like that I think it was 3.2
million and uh everybody told him he was
crazy there's nothing you could do with
this and he ended up connecting with
this guy Todd Richardson who is an art
Professor has like a PhD or a graduate
degree in I think Renaissance art but
that combination of those two
individuals created something very
unique which
was taking this property
and translating it into a symbol for a
future Memphis because Memphis of
course has a very
colorful and interesting history when we
think about Memphis we think about music
we think about the Civil Rights Movement
but all of that is looking in the rear
viw mirror and nobody was looking into
the future and saying what could Memphis
be or what is the vision for the Memphis
that we would like to you know sort of
give to Future generations and that's
the vision that kind of
infused what went into creating this
project and the fact that it is a
nonprofit that's really about the Arts
like the Arts is at the center of this
the Performing Arts Theater it's all run
by a nonprofit because typically
something like that best case scenario
it just gets turned into a massive mall
and it's about maximizing square feet
for revenue and this is not that in any
way shape or form no it's incredible and
it's um it's only like 5 years old which
is one of the reasons why I just feel
honored that they welcomed me into take
this really beautiful space um but the
the facility or the community is like
95%
least and so you know they have
residential you know on the upper floors
they have you know Church Health which
is 150,000 square feet Church Health has
28 dental chairs and they can do a crown
in an hour and a half wow it's
unbelievable and um and there's a YMCA
that's massive that's right Church
Health has YMCA connected to it they
have a pool they have a dog park they
they have a teaching kitchen also
exactly yeah they have teaching kitchen
so sham is looking forward to partnering
with them and and also we've been
talking to Maggie Barrett from support
and feed and um you know just be really
really awesome to just feed the
community out of those kitchens and you
know just uh just share life so it's
really super cool yeah it's very cool it
is um it is a place of uh you know
creativity for sure right and the fact
that shimu is right at the base of that
extraordinary red circular staircase
just is like chef's kiss like what you
did with the cafe um the design
everything about it is so elegant and it
was beautiful to have that reception and
have so many people come out to
celebrate um this new thing and listen
you know it's hard to move your business
to a state in a city where you don't
really know anyone and then throw party
and expect anybody to show up cuz you
were like I was like I don't know who to
call I I have nobody I can call I don't
know I don't know I don't know anybody
here um but you've been so supported by
Business Leaders in that Community who
really showed up for you and and the
turnout was really something special and
I mean one thing that I I feel like this
trip I really sort of put down some of
my roots I mean obviously it did open
the cafe but also um rented an amazing
home that I actually fell in love with
that took me back to my youth um it was
an amazing home and it reminded me of an
architectural home that I grew up in in
Alaska because my childhood friend Terry
Meyer um her family lived in lner and so
I spent many of my adolescent years
listening to Elton John smoking pot and
like you know doing gymnastics in this
amazing home that had an indoor Atrium
it was on a lake and it had you know the
Big Stone floors and also builtins
everything was built in all the couches
all the Upholstery and it just has the
this vibe to it you know it's like the
big Labowski you know famous house that
you know everybody knows from that movie
so this house definitely had some of
that vibe in a big way and when I picked
you and Tyler up from the airport you
know I was like I'm in the most
beautiful home I've ever seen in my life
and you know it's in Memphis like that
just makes no sense whatsoever so there
was a lot of stuff that was sort of on a
60-year cycle and also my opening
was on a solar eclipse the ring of fire
yeah a new moon solar eclipse it was
called the ring of fire and when I
arrived in Memphis uh one of my
teammates Aaron reminded me that the
song Ring of Fire was recorded in
Tennessee in
1961 so there was just a lot of magic
and so many people from the community in
Memphis came up to me and thanked me for
being there um it was really fun to see
them freak out over shimu they were just
devouring it and completely loving the
product um and you know Memphis is a a
very sacred place the lands are very
sacred the aquifers the trees and you
know the peoples and so um uh you know
people go to Memphis to create something
new you know and we've been welcomed to
be a part of that and I'm just very very
honored and excited about what that's
going to be in my life and and in our
[Music]
lives the other trip about Memphis is
the parallel with Egypt because you know
obviously there's a Memphis in Egypt and
if you're paying attention and driving
around Memphis you will see statues of
Ramsay and not only are there statues of
Ramsay this sort of note or Ode to the
other Memphis There's an actual pyramid
yes
there is like a giant mirrored pyramid
that's bigger than you might think it is
right in the middle of the city that I
think at one point was or it was origin
originally like a a music venue or a
sports venue but now it is the
headquarters it is like the flagship
store for Bass Pro Shops right when you
go in there the ceiling is like I don't
know 300 ft high or whatever it is um
and it's like a it's almost like an
amusement park in there like we had to
go and visit cuz I was like I have to
see this place it's a thing definely
thing yeah and Ramsay's the second
statue um also at University of Memphis
and um there's no accident definitely
there is a mystical connection to Egypt
and Memphis Egypt was the capital when
it was at its height so also not an
accident that you know in the recent
years I've been traveling to Egypt so
I'm I'm in I'm connected in Memphis
Egypt and Memphis Tennessee so we'll see
what what comes of it but uh something
is something is a foot for sure yeah um
the other cool thing um about cross town
that I experienced was that right above
your space is like right upstairs from
where you are is that art museum but
there's also creative offices and I met
um this filmmaker Craig Brewer who
houses his production uh office just
above you like literally right above you
um and he's the guy who wrote and
directed a film called Hustle and Flow
which in many ways is sort of an
archetypal film about Memphis he's done
other things he created that TV show
Terriers on FX and um he worked he's
worked with Eddie Murphy quite a bit I
think he coming to America to the second
coming coming to America movie um
Dolomite is my name black snake Moon and
just a filmmaker that I follow I
followed his career for a long time like
I remember when Hustle and Flow came out
that was a big deal uh big kind of like
independent Sundance Film that launched
Terence Howard's career and I was
thinking about that movie as I was
traveling to Memphis which was a city
I'd never been to before because that's
sort of the Cinematic cinematic like
footnote that I have in my mind about
What About Memphis and then it was so
wild it was like oh he's actually here
and we were up in his office like
talking to him it was crazy yeah it's
it's it's amazing there's so much
creativity oozing out of that community
in Cross Town is uh yeah everything that
they're doing is at the highest level so
it's like you know it's it's very very
well executed on every level so so what
are what are some of the I'm going to
pin you down here a little bit as an
entrepreneur who Moved their entire
business from where we live to a city
where you didn't really know anyone um
what were some of the lessons that you
learned or obstacles that you had to
confront and overcome to accomplish that
well I would say that it was definitely
harder than I imagined which is probably
a good thing because it gives you sort
of this naive um maybe luck that you
know makes you make these decisions to
do these things I think the biggest
thing that I learned is that early on in
my company I was leading more as a
mother you know I I have a lot of people
around me and want my children to have
everything you know not only my own
children but sort of everyone that I'm
working with
and I think early on in a
company's you know birth and Inception
it's appropriate like it it actually
works it's sort of like everybody's
doing everything and it's a little bit
more like a family and then when you
move into a place where you really have
to scale um it it I really can't leave
that way so I had you know the
entrepreneurial you know hard School of
Knox of learning how to you know um step
into really being the mother of shu as
my ultimate you know focus and
understanding that you know um you know
the business requires a certain level of
responsibility that you know that is
necessary to ensure her life and um so
that was you know I had wished that some
of my La team would have gone to cross
toown in Memphis and fallen in love and
moved there that's maybe a you know a
big wish it's a lot to ask someone ask
it's a lot to ask but you know um and so
that didn't really happen um and then it
became very clear that the business is
in Memphis so even though during coid we
were working remote like a lot of people
um you know we are you know we are a
kitchen facility production facility and
all of the opportunity is there in
Memphis so um you know we're building a
team we have an amazing uh crew right
now the quality of the cheese is
phenomenal and one of the challenges
that I had is that Tennessee egg uh
wanted us to prove our um our uh
expiration so we were stuck in a thre
Monon holding pattern um just for
wholesale not for subscription but um
but it's also good because you know we
hired a food scientist and we now have
you know even more um I would say gold
standards in place uh you know batching
so that we could recall should anything
happen but really what was proven is
just the amazing stability of Shu and
you know it it's just a very very stable
product right which is why if you live
in Los Angeles it wasn't available at
aan for for a period of time but it's
it's back I've seen it everywhere so
it's back it's back yeah and during that
time also that I'm in Memphis like we
were waiting for for our Organic
certification because we had to get
moved to Memphis to do that so there
were many things like I have new
products that are you know that we're
going to be releasing we have a butter
that we're coming out with it's
phenomenal it's the best thing you've
ever had and we have our first dessert
that we launched um shimu and uh we
hosted a dinner in Malibu last month um
to unveil our first dessert which is
called the mlay cake and um and so we're
shipping that right now and it's um just
extraordinary uh caca almost like a caca
mousse with hints of cayenne and um
cinnamon and uh dat and it's it's kind
of amazing it's cool yeah um how do you
make those decisions
around um adding SKS into the rotation
because I know you have a million
recipes and formulations and you could
just blow it out like tomorrow but you
have to be very careful about protecting
you know the core brand and the core set
of products and you've seen a lot of
companies who kind of too quickly start
like ramping up all their SKS and they
lose focus focus and there's a sort of
undermining of brand identity and it can
easily spiral out of control so it has
to be a
measured does I mean I'd say that you
know I've been on a leash for the whole
time we've been in La um and so and
that's because I understand from being a
fashion designer you know I made that
mistake you know I created a 100 piece
women's collection from sports wear to
evening
gowns and um you know it took me a while
to understand that I was you know that
there was no way that I could be
profitable with that much variety so
I've kept a very streamline in Shu and
you know of the eight flavors on our
collection they're all Extraordinary
like people say pick your favorite I
can't really I mean they they they all
stand uh on their own and they're all
really really strong and I have other
formulations that are extraordinary
equally as extraordinary and I think it
just it's just a matter of if production
can handle it and we have a really
extraordinary man uh with he comes from
management from FedEx and he's just into
numbers and delivery and um his name is
Daniel gleeton and uh he's just been a
treasure to us he's a gem so you know
what I'm getting now is where I used to
get we can't do that uh he just says
Julie that's my specialty so I'm really
loving Daniel right now no I'll I'll be
very mindful of it but you know I have a
mozzarella product that is the best that
I've ever tasted and so you know we're
also sort of ready to find the product
like the one the thing that really you
know sets us apart or maybe would be the
thing that we could scale really
gigantically so um the wheels are just
here to stay they're gorgeous um one of
the best things about the opening was
probably the most expensive thing in the
in the space is the Cold Case and I got
like this really gigantic like 6ot coal
case and with all the cheese stocked in
it when I slid the door open and smelled
it I mean it just smells like Paris like
it's so cheesy and so so much hits all
those notes that we love about Dairy
cheese um it's just extraordinary I mean
it's it was really really amazing and
what is it about like from a business
economic marketing perspective like what
is it about being in Memphis that makes
it better than being in Los Angeles like
I think just imagine somebody saying
well I still don't understand why you
move like why move your whole operation
but I mean even just if you just look at
just straight business uh which is not
what shimu is at all um Memphis is in
the top three cities to move your
business to Simply for cost simply cost
of operations and ease of operation um
for me really cross town Concourse was
the deciding factor um because Community
is is at the core of shimu like I don't
I don't really care so much of having my
cheese in a box in a store you know
that's great but what I really care
about is the conversations that it
ignites in people as they gather around
a box of cheese as you buy the box and
you create a board um and we're even
coming out with a series of like you
know inspirational questions or things
to ponder uh because every box of Shu
potentially activates let's say 13
people it's all about Community like I
care so much more about that
which is why I'm giving you guys a code
I I don't mean didn't mean to just segue
you're like Arnold schwarzeneger would
be very proud you his whole like cell
cell cell chapter you know in his book
like you're you're living it right now I
me but the thing is is it's like I
really do want to Foster subscriptions
because subscription aligns us through
this Common Thread and it is the
community and so we are working on
things like a secret menu only for
subscribers or a subscrip ition offering
where you can pay um a little more and
get you know uh special recipes or
healing techniques um the other thing
that we're doing is we are um
integrating water tiger which is my
spiritual mentorship with shimu so we're
not acting like you know we're not doing
any of the things that food companies do
like you know get your cheese for the
barbecue like that's just not me so what
is me is you know caring deeply about um
you know sending a loved one off who has
passed away and having a prayer or
knowing how to create an altar or how to
bless your food or how to nurture your
child through the difficult years of
adolescence um these type of things are
are core and being integrated into shimu
and so by fostering subscriptions it
allows us to join together around that
messaging and around those initiatives
that most of us you know care very much
about at least the people that are
eating what we call vibrational
nourishment and that's what trio is yeah
it's great I mean I know we all you know
like we buy products online and when
you're purchasing it's like click here
to receive you know emails with
discounts or whatever and I I never
click those but somehow I still end up
getting all of those and I spend you
know 20 minutes a day deleting all the
you know kind of marketing emails that
come in but there's a few that I
actually like because those emails are
really not about trying to sell you
anything they're branded of course but
they're more like magazines or they have
information that is thematically
relevant to whatever product they're
selling but they're providing value
beyond that and so I think the sense of
encouraging people to subscribe to the
newsletter because it's yeah you'll hear
about whenever there's a sale or
whatever but it's more about like um
exploring like the you know just the the
the lifestyle aspects that are
meaningful to you that you care about
that kind of Infuse the product are why
you created it to begin with yeah
definitely and luckily you know I have
my you know Ally in in life Mel nahas
the founder of conscious city guide who
is also the producer of our plant power
Retreats and I have the wonderful
privilege of you know sharing a
friendship and she's my brand lead and
also my Ops lead right now and she just
gets me and so she's never trying to
compartmentalize who I am and the food
company and you know some of the
newsletters that we sent out this month
were just really exciting you know they
were about you know 52 who is this
loneliest whale um who has a different
song than other whales and you know as
scientists have been tracking this being
and you know just bringing awareness to
the whales and to the care of these
magnificent beings and you know sharing
a documentary or sharing the sound bite
so these are the type of things I mean I
have a dream I'm going to say this now
cuz I have a dream so I want to just lay
it out here even though I'm way ahead of
myself but when I went to the Arctic
Circle last year um one of my water
tiger members um
SRI um she gifted me a trip there for my
birthday and she took me to this resort
called loten and I I've never felt more
alive or more on just on fire in a good
way like lit up as I was in the Arctic
Circle I can't explain it it was
something the coating coming off of the
mountains um the way you see dragons
everywhere you look it was just like a
Magical Kingdom and I was drinking
living tea like by a running River like
Gandalf just out there in the fairy land
and I went to a restaurant there and
there were surprisingly three vegan
options on the menu but two whale
options on the menu and I it just hit me
so hard and later I was at this surf
camp which is in loten and all these
beautiful young ones you know surfing in
this freezing water and they you know
had some vegan options in their Cafe but
shortly after that I said to srees and
malie who was my other friend the other
water tiger man member that came with us
um I said you know I want to I want to
open a Shu Shack in loten and I want to
align with some of these Surfers and
teach them how to make Shu and make a
documentary like I want to I want to go
bring Shu into the community and bring
awareness to Wales and sort of I don't
know offer a plant-based alternative uh
not not in a I mean this is something
that is of their lineage right so it it
it's a very ancient um but the fact that
these beings are still being slaughtered
is just unimaginable um so it's a crazy
dream that I have that I'll probably
start on next year it sounds like a a
Chris burkart movie Chris burkard are
you listening come to me he's the
perfect person come to me let's do this
together you're so such a beautiful
artist yeah I mean let's do it and this
is the type of thing that is exciting
the other thing that's really exciting
is I met the man and I'm forgetting his
name and I'm sorry um he created a
mobile uh clam like performance clam on
a truck and it's 900 square ft and he'll
take this venue on Wheels anywhere so um
my next thing is Mel and I are planning
a music a shimu music festival next year
um and it's it's this amazing uh venue
on Wheels so not like a clam like a
mollusk like a CL like a clam shell like
a stage yeah like a Hollywood Bowl or
whatever yeah from Bugs Bunny yeah I
mean it's epic and it's pretty new he
just finished it in the last couple
months and so so it just opens up and
you have an immediate portable stage
wherever you want to go and there's this
area called Shelby Farms in Shelby
Forest which is near Memphis and you
know it's a really beautiful area and so
I don't know I've got I've got some I've
got a little inspiration going on so
those are the two things that I'm so
excited about for 2024 yeah it's cool
I'm super proud of you I mean it's been
a long road to get to this place and it
was nice to celebrate you and see the
manifestation you know rot into three
dimensions thank you yeah and it's just
the beginning like now you can scale you
know now you have a home now you have a
foundation you've got a team
and um it's going to be really cool to
see what evolves from there thank you
babe it was super sweet having you guys
all there and yeah I don't know it like
I said it was um we are having dinner um
we had a a small dinner the night before
with Tom shadia and Todd and Lee
Richardson and Kemp and an Conrad and
some of our team June and Hansa who came
into help and um it it just felt like
all of a sudden we were kind of I was
kind of getting settled because you know
it's been difficult going to Memphis and
not knowing anyone and you know I have
like I would have a freak out sort of
every time I went thinking like what did
I do like why did I sign a 5year lease
here but there is a really cool
community of people and for people that
don't know I mean Tom shadia also was a
big initial instigator of you being
interested in this move because of what
he's doing with Memphis Rock So for
people that don't know Tom is a
legendary Hollywood filmmaker he made
the Lion Share of the huge um big
comedies of the 90s with Jim Carrey from
I don't Bruce Almighty Liar Liar like
some of them he produced some of the Ace
Ventura like all the he made all these
huge movies and then he had kind of an
existential crisis when he reached the
top of the mountain um and and went on
this kind of search for meaning and
purpose in his life uh that led him to
kind of divesting himself of of all of
his possessions moving to Malibu riding
around on a bike teaching at Pepperdine
um and making a documentary about this
experience called I am um which if you
haven't seen it we'll link it up in the
show notes it's it's like a mustsee it's
an incredible documentary um but he
ultimately ended up moving to Memphis he
left Los Angeles he has family roots in
Memphis um and he opened this thing
called Memphis rocks which is is it a
non it's a nonprofit right set up as a
nonprofit but it's basically an indoor
it's a massive indoor climbing facility
that is oriented
around um bringing in and supporting um
at risk and disadvantaged youth and
teaching them outdoor and adventure
skills and then taking them on
Expeditions um in fact a bunch of the
Memphis rocks climbers just went out and
climbed with Alex h
recently sh some photos of of that as
well yeah I was at dinner with Christine
who's one of the individuals he's a
beautiful film director an amazing human
and dear friend now and um he runs me
Memphis rock rocks in some capacity um
but anyway yeah I was having dinner with
him and then he said I just got back
from climbing with Alex so he showed me
a picture and then I texted it to you so
yeah it's funny yeah it's super cool and
then they're going like they do big
Expeditions on some of the big mountains
right yeah like kjaro or I don't know
yeah and my lead investor Tom Lawrence
who is the person who invested in me and
created my whole spiritual raise in in
the way that I wanted um is why I'm in
Memphis um Tom and his wife Ellie um
suggested I come check it out and so um
Tom Lawrence is also on the board at
Memphis rocks and also for anyone who's
listening this is just an amazing
initiative and it's not only a Climbing
gym it's a community center it offers
these kids like a place to go a place to
be safe and you know Tom has spent you
know a lot of his heart and soul and
blood and sweat and money um but he's a
beautiful beautiful human being and um
you know they are looking for support
for that because it's a it's it's a big
initiative yeah and needs more love and
more nourish I I I have to get Tom on
the podcast you have to get Tom on the
podcast I went back and searched through
all my emails to when we first got
introduced and it was 2014 that's how
long I've been I was waiting for shu to
open up well there was that but also
prior to that um the plan
was um to go to Memphis rocks and like
do it there and film it and like
experience the kids and all of that but
then Co happened and that all kind of
went away and so when we were in Memphis
that's the first time that I had um seen
him or spoke to him you know since those
those earlier convers well I think
there's a lot of opportunity to do that
and also in Cross Town you know there's
so much creativity and people that are
on The Cutting Edge of their Innovation
you know also um Matt Ross Spang or
Spang Ross I think it's Matt Ross Spang
um he's a music producer there that has
an amazing uh studio and they do 28
artists in residency a year um also we
have will mcgaan who is ml's Brother my
dear friend mlan
um it's her brother and he's has The
Woodworking Shop there so it's it's rad
wooding shop is insane it's insane yeah
what they're doing with wood in there I
mean it's full on and they have this
huge machine that's like the size of
this room I forget what it's called it's
called like a p& p or something like
that like matys knew what it was
basically it's a industrial size like
laser cutter for wood that typically
would only be used by developers who are
are you know building houses and
apartment complexes Etc but not
available to artists who want to do
something different with it and I think
so I think it's one of the very few that
exists that's available for um Artisans
and artists to do you know interesting
things very cool and I might have G I
might have said Will's last name wrong
might that might not be his name so
sorry if I got it wrong also I just want
to give a shout out to citywood who I
got these pop Live Edge shelves from um
there are a group of guys uh that are
farmers uh but they have the most
amazing reclaimed yard of just all kinds
of different varieties and they're in
Memphis Tennessee it's called citywood
and I just want to thank them for uh
making me these beautiful popular
shelves which is in it's local wood to
Memphis so anyway thanks guys in
celebration of you and seeing you and
being present with you um I want you to
know how proud I am of everything that
you have created this manifestation with
your company but also just the presence
that you have grown and matured into
like this incredibly wise being who has
a very unique and Powerful lens
on not just relationships but uh how to
be in the
world and I've watched as you've grown
into to that um and all the people who
um are comforted by what you share with
them and I think it's really a beautiful
unique expression a certain frequency
that you emit into the world that is
entirely your
own so I just wanted to recognize you
for that thank you for that thanks I
love you me too um before we go I think
you're offering up like a some kind of
deal on the Shu situation def okay so to
get your shu to get you some um we're
going to give uh 22% off on our new
dessert offering it's a two mousse cake
box it's called the mlay and uh so for
that code it's mlay 22 m a c l a
y22 and then uh we're going to give a
code RRP fam
um which is for the 13th box free of any
annual subscription you'll get the 13th
box free and what is that how much is
that off what you would normally it
depends because it depends on which
subscription you box so it's just
whichever subscription you buy you'll
get a free box so and you know that's
all in the spirit of um building our
family and community and keeping us
close and aligned and um so and thank
you to everyone who's supported me so
far um it's it's because of you guys
that I was able to launch this company
and um create this beautiful food as art
and so I hope you'll continue with me
along the journey thanks um you can
learn more about shrio sho.com uh and
you are at shrimati yes s r m a or Julie
pay.com and uh yeah for all the things
yeah and if you are enjoying um Julie
frequency uh you might want to check out
her water tiger Community which you can
find on your website as well right yeah
so it's um water tiger spiritual
Community mentorship um monthly call for
two hours and then you have access to
over 50 techniques to help put you in
the Gap um it's all
self-created um so you decide where to
enter and what to use um and it's a
beautiful Community all right to be
continued to be continued yeah all right
love you Bab I love you sweetheart peace
plants
Namaste that's it for today thank you
for listening I truly hope you enjoyed
the conversation to learn more about
today's guest including links and
resources related to everything
discussed today visit the episode page
at Rich roll.com where you can find the
entire podcast archive as well as
podcast merch my books Finding Ultra ing
change in the plant power way as well as
the plant power meal planner at meals.
rich.com if you'd like to support the
podcast the easiest and most impactful
thing you can do is to subscribe to the
show on Apple podcast on Spotify and on
YouTube and leave a review and or
comment supporting the sponsors who
support the show is also important and
appreciated and sharing the show or your
favorite episode with friends or on
social media is of of course awesome and
very helpful and finally for podcast
updates special offers on books the meal
planner and other subjects please
subscribe to our newsletter which you
can find on the footer of any page at
Rich roll.com Today's show was produced
and engineered by Jason Cameo with
additional audio engineering by Kale
Curtis the video edition of the podcast
was created by Blake Curtis with
assistance by our creative director Dan
Drake portraits by Davy Greenberg
graphic and social media assets courtesy
of Daniel CIS thank you Georgia Wy for
copywriting and website management and
of course our theme music was created by
Tyler Patt traper Patt and Harry mathys
appreciate the love love the support see
you back here soon peace plants
[Music]
namaste
h